نقطه الخلاف الابرز بين الصين وامريكا
وبين حين واخر يحبس العالم انفاسه خوفا من
نشوء حرب بين القوتين العظمتين لكن لنفترض
ان ذلك حدث اين ستكون نقطه البدايه لتلك
الحرب صحيفه
المستقبليه ستقع في جزيرتكوا هذه الجزيره
تقع اقصى غرب امريكا في المحيط الهادئ
يبلغ طولها ثمانيه واربعين كيلو مترا فقط
ويصل عدد سكانها الى 170 الف نسمه وتعد
نقطه ضعف لدى امريكا
واشار الى ان الصين تضع جوان في مرمى
نيرانها بدليل ان
ها اطوان على صاروخ دي اف 26 لديها في
المقابل فان الدفاع الامريكي عن الجزيره
يعتبر ضعيفا فعلى سبيل المثال نظام الدفاع
الجوي فيها مصمم لتفادي الهجوم من كوريا
الشماليه وليس الصين كما ان بطاريته لا
تعمل باستمرار وعليه طلب البنتاغون
ميزانيه للعام القادم بقيمه مليار ونصف
المليار دولار بهدف تعزيز الدفاعات الجويه
للجزيره فهل تنقذ امريكان نقطه تضعفها قبل
فوات الاوان